bonjour à tous merci de me retrouver sur
public sénat à suivre cet après-midi sur
notre antenne une table ronde consacrée
à la place de l'esthétique dans la ligne
éditoriale de la presse magazine
cette table ronde a été organisée hier
par la mission commune d'information du
sénat sur les implants et les prothèses
à visée médicale mais aussi esthétique
objectif de cette mission éviter un
nouveau scandale sanitaire comme celui
des prothèses pip et je vous rappelle
que d'après le dernier bilan diffusé par
les autorités sanitaires en france mi
mars
20% des femmes porteuses de prothèses
mammaires pip et se les étaient fait
retirer tout de suite donc cette table
ronde bonne après midi à tous mes chers
collègues nous reprenons donc notre
suite d'auditions en terminant plus tôt
par une table ronde avec les
représentantes de la presse notamment
féminine donc des représentantes du
journal el du journal gracia et du
journal marie claire qui va qui a été
invitée et qui va nous rejoindre je dois
juste vous dire que je regrette un peu
qu au delà de ces trois jours qui sont
très importants sur notre dans notre
pays
d'autres représentants de la presse et
notamment féminine n'ait pas souhaité
participer à nos échanges
c'est vrai que vous avez aujourd'hui des
tirages à plusieurs milliers
d'exemplaires
et donc c'est intéressant d'échanger
avec vous pour mieux comprendre la façon
dont vous traitez ces questions
d'esthétique au sens large que ce soit
la chirurgie esthétique ou la médecine
la médecine esthétique tout donc les
différentes pratiques
d'esthétique sujets sur lesquels on se
penche depuis trois mois géorgie mais
aussi vraiment j'insiste sur la médecine
d'esthétique
deuxième élément qui est très
intéressant c'est que vous contribuer
d'une manière ou d'une autre à créer des
tendances alors je sais pas si on va
dire créer dé créer des mods en tout cas
à promouvoir des techniques et vous êtes
souvent aussi le relais de ces de ces
différentes techniques
donc nous c'est vraiment on n'est pas du
tout donc comme je vous le disais avant
de commencer on n'est pas du tout dans
un jugement de valeur
ni dans un jugement positif et le
négatif on veut vraiment comprendre la
manière dont vous même vous faites vos
sujets est ce que ce qui vous revient
parce qu'il ya aussi souvent le
témoignage des des lectrices ou des
lecteurs
ces dommages n'ont pas de représentants
des magazines masculins il y en a ils
marchaient d'esthétique masculin se
développe aussi de manière très très
important donc je dois vous rappeler
donc cette table ronde est ouverte au
public à la presse qu'elle fait l'objet
d'un enregistrement et qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site du
sénat
si vous en êtes d'accord très bien avant
2 avant de vous donner la parole je
laisse la parole à notre rapporteur
monsieur bernard cazeau très bien si
vous voulez je voudrais d'abord vous
demander des choses qui est assez simple
pour nous dire quelle est la place que
vous accordez à l'esthétique et aux
interventions à visée esthétique qu'elle
soit médical ou non l'arrivée du tauriel
de vos magazines avec quelle régularité
sous quel angle alors les angles c'est
la santé la beauté la promotion
l'information la mise en garde ou
peut-être d'autres de tels thèmes sont
ils aborder dans vos colonnes
mettez le micro et par les prêts vous
appuyez sur le bouton rouge alors
c'était la régularité
déjà on a des ailes à plusieurs
plusieurs numéros anti âge par an au
moins deux je pense peut-être 3d font un
maintenant 1 à la rentrée et peut-être
qu'il y en aura un aussi en fin d'année
ça c'est pour la régulation c'est pour
les numéros obligatoires
ça nous empêche pas de traiter d'autres
sujets en fonction d'actu typiquement
les peaux la cepal anti âge mais les
prothèses pip et pour ce qui concerne
les dispositifs médicaux
voilà et puis et puis ça nous empêche
pas de traiter aussi des deux sujets sur
wii c'est plutôt liée à l'actuel ensuite
ce dieu médicaux ou non oui plutôt mais
des copains ça dépend anti âge ça peut
être dax sous forme de crèmes médecine
esthétique chirurgie esthétique médicaux
quand ces pays quand c'est les prothèses
etc médical oui donc tout tout tout tout
confondu en général on traite tout ton
on essaie d'avoir le plus plusieurs
volets en même temps fait le son mais il
ya toujours une dimension esthétique de
toute façon dans vos publications
oui ce sont des oui oui oui cissé qui
tradent de ceux là sont des spécialistes
vous avez chez vous c'est là entre
autres
non mais il ya des médecins pour les
suivants mais l'icône vous face à la
paire de manches et interfère des mets
pas une interview plus bien sûr mais
c'est pas les auteurs de l'article qui
sont interrogés et on enquête auprès
d'eux mais mais c'est à eux qui écrivent
lesquels sont les rubriques je vous
demande est là si vous pouvez le
prestigieux régulière par exemple votre
santé par exemple
non on n'a pas une rubrique si
régulières que ça c'est de traiter dans
l'arbre et dans le ca par le service
beauté donc dans toute la section beauté
mais ya pas une rubrique qui reviendrait
chaque semaine votre santé qui seraient
consacrées à l'anti âge ou à la médecine
esthétique
voilà après c'est vraiment en fonction
de l'acte eu des tendances de ce qu'on a
envie d'y mettre mais c'est pas
obligatoire dans tous les numéros
at-elle page tel espace pour sa création
c'est pareil toujours à ces jeux wii
j'allume la petite lumière rouge
oui enfin moi je dirais que en fait on
fait quand même un suivi régulier de
tout ce qui se passe en esthétique et
avec différents angles vraiment selon
l'actualité selon le mode du moment donc
moi je dirais qu'en moyenne on pourra
avoir une accroche par mois en
esthétique en sachant qu'on hebdomadaire
donc en fait ça fait un numéro sur
quatre en accroche esthétique au sens
large anti-âge esthétique
voilà mes donc justement ce que je
voulais vous dire par rapport aux angles
qui était qui était proposé donc soit on
fait des sujets thématiques régulier
donc comme disait ma collègue c'est à
dire que nous parents on a un rajeunir
qu'on estampille rajeunir donc qui
constitue quasiment 50 pages du journal
qui est consacré à cette demande
on va dire il ya cette recherche des
femmes au sens large rajeunir on peut
discuter du mou rajeunir évidemment tout
peut se discuter mais voilà ça c'est une
accroche important du journal
et c'est effectivement un numéro qui se
vendent bien on a aussi des accroches
spécial kg alors on appelle plus à
maigrir maintenant on est passé au kilo
voilà un changement de thématiques on va
dire mais en gros main parce que
justement la notion de maigrir est ce
que c'est vraiment une notion à
véhiculer auprès des femmes voilà on
discute beaucoup des mots qu'on utilise
c'est très très important
on a aussi ce qu'on appelle nous un
spécial cellulite là donc ça c'est un
mot français claude dans têtu et qui est
ambitieux la soca dans les résultats oui
mais qui marche aussi bien enfin en tout
cas on essaye c'est une préoccupation
des femmes en fait c'est ça aussi je
voulais vous dire mon en préambule
en fait on n'est que le reflet de la
préoccupation des femmes
c'est à dire que moi je considère que
nos sujets sont inspirés par leur part
les femmes leurs préoccupations et en
fait nous sommes des vraies éponges de
ce qui se passe dans la tête et dans le
corps des femmes en crétins et et on
essaye de leur apporter et où des
réponses ou des éclairages mais on n'a
pas la science exacte non plus on se
considère pas du tout comme ça on
recherche des legs passe notre temps à
faire ça à tester à essayer à voir aller
dans les congrès à se renseigner sur ce
qui se fait et et à leur faire part de
ce qu'on entend en fait c'est ça notre
notre point de vue donc les femmes ont
des attentes des espérances des envies
mais elles ont aussi des méfiances des
interrogations et notre métier c'est ça
c'est de céder les aider dans ce domaine
là
je disais des sujets thématiques donc
par an mais il ya évidemment des sujets
ponctuels
alors qu'ils sont avec différents angles
par exemple des angles psy ou estime de
soi qui sont plus sous forme de
témoignages de vécu on tend le micro aux
femmes ou aux hommes d'ailleurs donc par
exemple on avait fait un sujet la
chirurgie esthétique a changé ma vie
l'objectif commence à la changer en quoi
et c'est donc c'était à l écoute des
femmes bien sûr mais aussi comme un
collègue le disais donc des sujets
d'actu lié à un phénomène où et comment
dire quelque chose qui est complètement
d'actualité dont on entend parler donc
par exemple un sujet qui qui peut amener
la polémique mais qui était intéressant
qui s'appelle le vampire lift enfin
qu'on avait appelé le vampire lift en
fait c'est une technique qui consiste à
on va dire récupérer du sang des
patients de le passer enfin c'est c'est
le sentry fusée et après le réinjecter
dans le visage donc ça c'est ça fait
peur donc on enquête sur le sujet nous
c'est pas de dire allez-y les femmes
fait ça ça marche
en plus on sait pas voilà donc justement
on enquête isabelle ici présente enquête
donc elle a suivi les congrès et c'est
sûr sur ce sujet on a fait des sujets
aussi par exemple sur le laser
fractionné ou sur la cryothérapie qui
est une technique d'amincissement on va
dire en fait plus de deux longueurs de
là dessus bien sûr on fera bien sûr mais
simuler une fête que vous faites là pour
la présentation et la mise en garde le
pour le contre
voilà on passe notre temps à ça à
enquêter là-dessus à le dire a essayé de
faire la part des choses mais surtout en
fait plus à donner les éléments cas
jugés on n'est pas là nous non plus pour
juger les techniques parce que je n'ai
pas moi par exemple le monde entier
arrivent c'est quelque chose qui peut me
faire peur moi personnellement mais je
connais des femmes qui l'ont fait et je
vais pas stigmatiser les femmes qui
l'ont fait pour autant je vais aller les
voir je vais leur tendent le micro je
leur demandais pourquoi elles l'ont fait
dans quelles circonstances est ce que ça
leur a fait mal est-ce qu'elles ont eu
des résultats etc
bon voilà donc ça c'est des sujets
ponctuels précis sur des techniques
précises par exemple est bon j'en amen
est aussi bien sûr et donc ça
la même chose à des polémiques
d'actualité mais là c'est ce qu'on
disait par exemple sur les prothèses pip
sur les cabines uv à attention au botox
sur le net
voilà le blanchiment des dents lambinet
en ville et c'est là qu'ils sont
vraiment traités comme des sujets
polémiques et qui sont plus qu'ils
viennent plus en fait c'est ce qu'on
disait aussi tout à l'heure dans nos
magazines
il ya une partie beauté à part entière
dont je suis la laque chef mais il ya
aussi une partie magazine bien entendu
là on va dire que selon les sujets on
les traite dans telle ou telle partie du
magazine pour être plus à chaud ou pour
avoir un peu plus de distancer un peu
plus de une dimension plus large d'un os
dans nos articles
voilà mes lacunes dans la préparation de
vos articles
quel est le travail de recherche ou pour
mener un travail de recherche en publié
vous voyez des spécialistes vous vous
faites une enquête sur le sujet alors
est ce que l et approfondie ou est-ce
que liszt et une enquête rapidement
faite sur ces sujets là je dois dire
qu'elle est toujours très approfondie
quand c'est des sujets de santé ou de
médecine esthétique c'est d'autant plus
approfondie ça il faut le savoir
c'est à dire que c'est des sujets qu'on
ne publie pas si on n'a pas fait relire
le sujet si on n'a pas vraiment enquêter
c'est ya une on est obligé de prendre
vraiment extrêmement peu de précautions
là dessus oui en fait on est quand même
beaucoup lui il faut donc on n'a pas le
ralliera bon c'est pas pour autant que
et en plus fait confiance aux
spécialistes pour nous appeler si par
hasard
il ya des erreurs et en plus ce jour
parce qu on pourrait raconter si on
n'était pas en fait qui je vois pas ce
qu on pourrait raconter si on enquêtait
pas non mais moi je vous pose des
questions mais je la d'avancé ça là
c'est qu'on est obligé d'enquêté on est
obligé ans et ne rien connaître ce que
vous faites dans une pose des questions
et c'est vrai je connais pas grand chose
certaine masse que vous faites ne
faisait donc je m'instruis je pense oui
c'est ça c'est à dire qu'on est en tout
cas on se considèrent ni comme de vrais
journalistes on essaye à part entière
comme des journalistes économiques on en
importe quel domaine enquête sur les
sujets sur lesquels on avait fait
beaucoup d'articles sur les ratés comme
les prothèses pip est oui prothèse
papier sur leur wii on fait beaucoup ont
fait aussi bien des sujets que ce soit
d'actualité sur ce qui sur les points
positifs que sur les points négatifs on
n'est pas là pour dire il faut
absolument le faire on est là pour dire
les femmes sont libres de faire ce
qu'ils veulent on est là pour leur dire
voilà le pourvoi là le contre donc il
c'est vrai qu'il ya régulièrement aussi
des sujets sur le botox qui est trop
injecté qui a eu des problèmes aux états
unis avec des maux de tête et juste
comme ça donc on enquête là-dessus on
n'est pas toujours
vous voyez on est obligé d'avoir deux de
parler aussi des problèmes de rater et c
est aussi toujours dans les papiers dire
quand on fait un article sur une
nouvelle technique nous n'avons pas
encore assez de recul
c'est à titre informatif et nous
précisons toujours que nous n'avons pas
de recul et nous préciserons aussi cote
hotu aucune étude scientifique n'a été
fait et surtout n'a été publié dans un
journal de référence
cette cible est une des bandes consommer
que le club
on va passer peut-être un petit peu la
publicité là puisque vous a quand même
des journaux j'ai vu pas mal de
publicité à quelqu'un a lancé je posais
une question je voudrais savoir si vous
considérez que les articles que vous
publiez sur des articles à base
scientifique reconnue ou 6 et des
articles de vulgarisation
en ce qui me concerne mon journal qui
marie claire je considère que ce sont
les articles de vulgarisation parce que
je ne suis pas un journal scientifique
je suis un journal pour les grosses
division donc je suis là je suis dans le
secteur là de vulgarisation oui donc
c'est la même chose pour nous au l on
interviews des experts et après on se
fait notre idée est donc on explique si
une technique est très nouvelle
comme le disait ariane golden est les
nouvelles donc est ce qu'il ya des
études ou non et on interview un certain
nombre de spécialistes mais après c'est
évidemment aussi à nous de nous faire
notre idée en fonction du nombre de
spécialistes qu'on a interviewé qui sont
eux les experts je vais vous
voulez vous je précise un peu plus moi
ce qui m'inquiète le petit peu ça semble
que c'est un sujet délicat qui devient
de plus en plus sérieux parce qu'il mise
en cause de la santé et même parfois au
delà
et est ce que vous pensez pas que avec
une vulgarisation eux on ne dérive pas
vers des risques de d'encourager
certaines personnes et que ces personnes
pourraient être victimes
en quelque sorte non pas de votre part
mais à travers la lecture qu'elle peut
voir votre journal d'un abus de
faiblesse
c'est que de toute façon qu'on soit là
ou pas là
elles iront celles qui veulent aller
faire quelque chose elles iront le faire
alors autant les prévenir du pour et du
contre et des risques qu'elle encourt
connaissez bien les femmes
jallet a ajouté que même parfois mon
avis oui les hommes aussi peut-être
moins facilement mais pardon je voulais
ajouter que parfois même sali dissuade
parce que moi j'ai souvent des échos de
certains articles en disant oh là là ça
fait peur ce que tu as écrit j'irai pas
donc oui c'est pas forcément ce n'est
pas c'est ce qu'on disait au début on
n'est pas là pour promouvoir une
technique on est là pour renseigner
donner un maximum d'informations sur ce
qui existe
afin que les femmes et les éléments de
décision pour savoir si jamais elle
envisageait de recourir à un acte
esthétique ce qu'elles peuvent en penser
si c'est enfin voilà on enviait et je le
précisais aussi qu'en ce moment par
rapport à ce mouvement de médecine
esthétique de tout ce qu'on veut il ya
un contre mouvement qui va avec le
mouvement naturel de biologie qui sont
des techniques totalement sève simple de
massage manuel où il ya aucun risque qui
sont vraiment que les femmes demandent
si vous voulez en opposition à ça pour
ça qu'ils ne veulent pas ça donc c'est
intéressant de voir en ce moment
justement qu'il ya des femmes qui
choisissent autre chose donc nous aussi
on suit ce qu'elles veulent et on leur
donne des informations sur ces autres
techniques qui sont des techniques tout
à fait naturel j'ai l'impression d'un
grade ya d'ailleurs on
du pain j'ai dit que dans le gras dia
j'ai l'impression que je passe
on passe notre temps plutôt à les
dissuader à leur dire attention voilà ce
qui existe mais faites attention prenez
pas
enfin prenez vos précautions
assurez-vous que ceux-ci et puis sinon
essayez quand même les pincements
jacques et essayez plutôt les massages
machin c'est plus j'ai l'impression que
nous on prompt
on pousse plus vers des méthodes
naturelles et plus naturel à la fois
dans la dans la technique et aussi à la
fois dans le résultat nous fallait une
cible qui est plus jeune
oui et comme travail ont quand même je
nous faisons des c'est l'autre côté
c'est ce qui marche et donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que comme nous avons
vous savez on travaille quand même les
journaux on se rappelle des cibles d'âge
donc quand on a une cible jeune c'est
vrai qu'on n'en est pas encore là
nous quand on travaille qu'on a on est
en phase de groupes de femmes qui sont
plus âgés elle nous demande on sait
qu'il ya une demande d'information là
dessus
donc nous on est aussi obligé de
répondre à cette demande donc on est
obligé de faire des dossiers là dessus
de gros échanges avec votre lectorat
enfin bien sûr c'est notre eau et notre
caisse de résonance si vous voulez nos
lectrices justement sur vous disiez que
vous étiez le reflet des préoccupations
des femmes comment est-ce que ces
préoccupations vous remonte par des
étudiants pour deux choses d'abord nous
sommes des femmes
et quand on est journaliste on est bien
ce que 10ème compteur des éponges
donc on sent les choses on rencontre on
voit on voit les et les marchés ont pas
ce qui marche donc on a une espèce
d'intuition d'un côté si vous voulez et
de l'autre côté nous avons des services
de marketing nous avons des tables
rondes avec des lectrices régulière nous
avons et en à paris et en province
et donc on a une remontée de leurs
demandes
et donc pour pour passer à un autre
sujet si tu vois on a épuisé celui-là en
matière de publicité se vengeront sombre
il ya beaucoup de publicité dans les
journaux ce qui est normal mais se voit
sa vie comment comment est ce qu'il y a
une règle de choix ou exclus ben tant
mieux si ça vient et on ponctionne est
terminée ou est-ce que vous êtes capable
d'avoir une règle éthique
par exemple on passe pas une publicité
qui nous paraît dangereuse par exemple
est ce que est ce que vous vous avez un
des règles éthiques en matière de
publicité ou est ce que vous prenez tout
ce qui arrive
il coûtait alors c'est un domaine qui
relève d'une services publicitaires et
donc c'est très dans les journaux c'est
très séparés la rédaction la publicité
sont très séparés
donc nous nous faisons toutes parties de
services de la rédaction
mais je crois savoir il faudrait vous
renseigner qu'une loi fait que nous
n'avons pas le droit de refuser que de
la pub je crois il faut google c'est pas
un plus non plus je crois que vous
n'avez pas droit donc regarder parce que
justement je
je ne crois que une règle cela dit je
n'ai jamais vu de publicité pour des
pour des injectables pour décider à
passer y adhérer la wii alors il ya des
publicités pour les injectables et
surtout ce qu'on a vu il ya quelques
années que c'est un petit peu calmé ces
des publicités pour des centres des
cliniques privées et des choses comme ça
et donc ça ils avaient le droit il ya
une loi qu'ils avaient le droit et je
crois que un magazine n'a pas le droit
de le de refuser donc ça c'est à
vérifier mais comment voulez vous non
plus c'est très difficile de refuser à
quelqu'un ait pas à quelqu'un d'autre
de quels critères on sait qu'il ya
grippe a c'est qu'il ya des produits qui
sont dangereux ils sont amène aussi qui
s'ensuivraient sur le marché si vous
avez une publicité pour ce produit
le passé mais je crois qu'on n'a pas le
droit de refuser
c'est à vérifier mais je crois qu'on n'a
pas le droit de refuser une publicité
dans un magazine à des produits
dangereux
regardez maintenant je dois vous dire
une chose à propos je vois la région
longtemps sur wii regarder avec
l'augmentation
maintenant je vais vous préciser un cas
qui a été il n'ya pas très longtemps
justement sur des produits dangereux
vous mettez une firme française qui va
sortir un produit injectable par exemple
et qui a besoin d'un marquage c'est eux
elle peut tout à fait demander
l'homologation ses oeufs dans un autre
produit dans un autre pays que la france
ce qui s'est passé dans un autre pays et
revenir est vendu en france
revenir est vendu en france mais hélas
ce moment-là et l'apsap est intervenue
et à ce moment-là ya problème des cibles
et l'exigence du marquage ce est vu d'un
produit n'est pas la même dans les
différents pays européens
alors que le marquage si vous laissez
eux ils eux mêmes
donc pour nous si vous voulez le cee
tech est un pas pour nous mais on sait
que c'est mais est une garantie quelque
part il faut savoir qu'elle n'est pas
celui de même qualité selon les pays et
que y'a des firmes qui arrive à la voir
dans d'autres pays
et donc ils ne sont pas des produits
très très sérieux en sécurité qui en
plus le marquage ce et c'est une
garantie de production mais pas de
sécurité sanitaire oui voilà ça veut
dire qu'il a été produit
conformément à un cahier des charges je
ne sais pas quoi mais ça veut pas dire
qu'il est inoffensif pour la santé oms
n'a connaissance
typiquement la wii vous êtes tous
journalistes et vous venez de nous dire
que vous êtes excessivement sensible aux
désirs aux besoins aux souhaits
d'information du public femmes en
particulier pourquoi pas du public ont
également tenu les 10 pour tout ce qui
concerne les les problèmes de santé de
beauté donc quelque sorte vous êtes
assez sensible à trouver la cible qui
correspond dans votre journal vous
cherchez vous identifier une cible par
rapport à un besoin de façon
effectivement à ce que votre journal
puisse avoir un article qui suscite chez
les intéressés
l'achat de votre de votre journal alors
tu aussi qui répondent à leurs attentes
je pose la question est-ce que la cible
vous l'a déterminé en fonction d'autres
critères que celui de la vente du
journal et deuxième question je viendrai
pas comme ça il semble effectivement a
trait à ce que nous dit que des femmes
pourquoi pas les hommes sont aujourd'hui
très sensible à tout ce qui concerne
leurs soins de beauté et de bien-être
et pourquoi pas de recul et le
vieillissement au temps suspends ton vol
et oui et vous heures propices attica
bank ça aussi bien que moi donc je
voudrais poser avec deuxième question
existe-t-il pour vous une frontière
entre les actions de santé
l'action de bien-être et les actions de
beauté et ce alors juste pour terminer
pour répondre à votre dernière seconde
question
la grande différence étant que dans les
questions de santé
il peut y avoir urgence alors que dans
les questions de beauté
antivieillissement il n'ya jamais
urgence donc il y a toujours réflexion
donc on dit toujours à nos lectrices
surtout ne dites pas neuneu
allez il faut réfléchissez
c'est toujours tentant et prenez le
temps de la réflexion
grande différence pour nous le temps de
la réflexion le temps de consulter
différents spécialistes on leur dit
toujours qu'il faut avoir plusieurs avis
voilà de rencontrer différents
spécialistes
voilà un de voir combien sa valeur quid
de réfléchir voilà vraiment réfléchir
d'ailleurs une fois de plus on n'est pas
les seuls intermédiaires par rapport à
ces femmes aussi c'est ce que je voulais
dire jeudi quand on l'est d'abord on les
renvoie jamais vert des médecins précis
puisqu'on fait jamais la publicité pour
un médecin en particulier mais
évidemment il ya quand même des
intermédiaires alors parfois des
esthéticiennes parfois des kinés mais
qui sont des espèces et des médecins
dermatologues et chirurgiens et c'est
qu'ils sont eux qui doivent faire leur
métier aussi je veux dire nous on fait
notre chacun fait non fait le nôtre
d'information mais les médecins et voire
même liste est ici n ont fait des études
doivent avoir des diplômes ont des
compétences et doivent les partager avec
avec leurs clients tout avec avec les
femmes qui reçoivent chez eux c'est
c'est très important aussi c'est
triangulaire cette histoire c'est pas
que want one mais je crois que des
choses qui est très importante c'est
c'est justement ce délai de réflexion
est d'ailleurs que les médecins les bons
médecins doivent respecter certaines
respecte certaines ne respecte pas mais
je crois que ça c'est indispensable ce
délai de réflexion parce que vous savez
très bien c'est que c'est le
rajeunissement
c'est quelque chose auquel tout le monde
aspire
lettres l'homme comme la femme sont
faibles et quand on vous promet ce genre
de choses on a envie d'y croire
donc sur le moment quand le médecin ou
le chirurgien vous le propose
on a envie de le faire tout de suite et
après vous rentrez chez vous vous en
parler autour de vous tout est l'arrêt
fait la réflexion commence et vous
attendait peut-être un peu et vous voyez
quelqu'un d'autre je crois que ce temps
de réflexion est très très important
parce que je le répète encore tout ce
qui est médecine esthétique ou chirurgie
il n'ya jamais d'urgence donc si je
comprends bien
excusez-moi la présidente j'ai repris la
parole sans simplement si j'ai bien
compris dans votre action de
journalistes vous faites bien attention
en somme apporter une information sur
des bases que vous avez vérifié en dix
ans en plus de ça vous êtes-vous dit
prenez le temps de la réflexion
en quelque sorte vous dites vous
privilégié de loi l'information et vous
prêts vous faites attention de ne pas
avoir un article qui puisse être de
l'incitation
je crois que c'est un domaine dans
lequel par rapport à jeudi
la coiffure le maquillage et tout ça où
on incite beaucoup moins si vous voulez
on sait qu'ils ont connaît on sait qu'il
ya toujours du d'un risque et qu'il ya
c'est quand même un domaine qui est très
très délicat et qui est délicat et
surtout qui est très opérateurs
dépendants voyez ce que je veux dire
il ya des mesures vous avez la même
femme elle va avoir un bon et un mauvais
ça va réussir sur elle ou pas sur elle
donc oublié il ya un facteur aléatoire
aussi qui est très important de
connaître obligé de deux de tenir compte
de cette marge l'a27 aléatoire la voyez
c'est pour ça qu'on est toujours plus
prudent que dans un autre domaine
et moi je voulais ajouter qu'on est
d'autant plus prudent que à partir du
moment où la médecine esthétique se
développe tout le monde a tendance à
croire que c'est moins invasive que la
chirurgie ce qui est vrai mais ce n'est
pas pour autant anodin et donc il ya
comme le disait ariane des risques et on
ne va pas chez le médecin esthétique
comme on va chez son coiffeur ou chez
moi lentilles sienne et donc ça il ne
faut jamais l'oublier
et donc c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'on a nous à redire dans nos articles
en disant une injection c'est pas
effectivement du bistouri on passe pas
sur le billard mais c'est quand même y
aller au risque de d'une petite réaction
inflammatoire enfin il peut toujours se
passer quelque chose après donc ce n'est
pas quelque chose d'anodin ça ne laisse
jamais et surtout et surtout on leur
précise bien pour certaines techniques
il y a tant d'années de recul
vous avez des nouvelles quand on a une
nouvelle machine on présente une
nouvelle machine très souvent dans ce
qui est très très nouveautés on ne le
traite pas parce qu'on attend de voir
parce que s'il voulait le problème qu'il
ya aujourd'hui avec ces machines c'est
que si vous voulez les je puis dire le
panel de test se fait dans le cabinet du
médecin si vous voulez il de comme les
études coûtent très cher et donc ce que
nous ne voulons pas c'est que nous ne
voulons pas que nos lectrices wade
cobayes donc on attend qu'il ait fait
des études pour pour en parler sans
arrêt obligé de résister ça je vous le
dis parce que mais nous nos lectrices ne
sont pas des cobayes ce que est ce que
vous favorisez vos lignes éditoriales
vers un certain style de femme ou est-ce
que c'est très généraliste est ce que
vous allez par exemple rompant une
certaine époque on a vu le style
mannequin qui faisait qui a fait
quelques ravages notamment en matière de
respect et les jeunes
oui est-ce que vous favorisez femmes
jeunes dynamiques vont en pleine de vie
et cetera et cetera
ou est-ce que vous alors ce qui
n'empêche pas de parler du reste
ou est-ce que vous avez une ligne
éditoriale qui bon qui prend tous les
âges et qui traite en fonctionnement
alors pour répondre à la première
question
messieurs on a dit au magazine dans mon
magazine marie claire on a ce qu'on
appelle une cible très large qui va de
17 à jusqu'au bout oui même plus donc si
vous voulez on a un grand panel donc
d'une part donc on s'adresse à un grand
nombre
c'est une première chose et une seconde
chose c'est que on est on est dans un
magazine nous pour lequel on laisse une
grande liberté aux femmes c'est quand
même un magazine qui était qui et
militant féministe
donc si vous voulez on fait beaucoup
d'articles aussi belle avec mes rides
plus belle à 60k à 30
il ya énormément de d'articles comme ça
parce que c'est une réalité aussi
aujourd'hui compensateur oui non pas
compensateur parce que c'est un reflet
d'une société aussi aujourd'hui si vous
voulez entre une femme de 55 ans
aujourd'hui est une femme de 55 ans il
ya vingt ans elle fait beaucoup plus
jeunes aujourd'hui donc et une réalité
aussi le l'espérance de vie augmente
et si vous voulez tout le curseur est
décalé donc mais il est vrai que
justement parce que cette espérance de
vie augmente et parce que les les femmes
et les hommes aujourd'hui veulent rester
non pas tellement beau mais dynamique
avec de l'énergie
c'est au delà de ça c'est outre au delà
de l'aspect esthétique parce que il ya
aussi toutes les gélules avaler il ya
tous les tests génétiques qui vont
exploser dans les années qui viennent
qui vont être aussi un marché veuille
avoir tout et n'importe quoi ils ça
commence si vous voulez donc cesser la
partie esthétique n'est que vraiment
c'est le début si vous voulez et donc
cette espérance de vie qui est en train
d'augmenter fait que y accueillaient
qu'il ne demandait que tous les curseurs
sont déplacés
et vous mesdames je ne sais pas à chaque
fois jusqu'à ce que la question qu'on
nous pose le sujet mardi
vous avez quel âge en inde comment on
etc nous on est leur faim je répète
toujours un peu la même chose mais le
reflet des femmes
moi j'ai pas l'impression de travailler
pour un journal qui ne visent qu'un type
de femme mais alors pas du tout du tout
hein on est très on a un panel très
large
tu commences à 17 mois je peux commencer
à 5 ans enfin bon c'est presque à non
c'est vrai c'est c'est un journal qui
est regardé par tout le monde et qui
compte un quine fait dans la maison d'en
regarder par les hommes on a trente 30 %
de lecteurs enfin bon d'acheteurs bon
donc je peux pas dire que je m'adresse
enfin c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible
donc oui les foyers ce que se dire t'as
dire que peut-être content tout vers des
idées aux cons à toutes nos idéaux en
tête et 2 et 2,2 d'image corporelle et
d'image intellectuelle et d'image
physique et de de l'image qu'on donne de
nous même peut-être du dynamisme
oui ça c'est vrai que j'essaye de donner
du dynamisme et lectrices j'essaye
d'être optimiste c'est vraiment ça à
notre esprit à elle c'est voilà c'est un
état d'esprit donc ça oui l'état
d'esprit mais tout le monde peut la voir
c'était à l'esprit ce que monsieur le
rapporteur vous poser comme question
vous que vous avez un certain recul
notamment par vos groupes de parole ou
de référence est justement quelle grande
évolution vous avez constaté sur ces
sujets dans le temps fin vers où va la
demande aujourd'hui et d'autre part
c'est totalement lié et qu'elle est là
la référence est la référence esthétique
c'est lorsque vous êtes en train de dire
ce que j'ai lu d'ailleurs par ailleurs
que le code de l'esthétique et est moins
sûr
la beauté que sur le caractère dynamique
oui juste pourra intervenir moi je dis
par exemple ce que les femmes aiment le
plus en ce moment elles ne veulent pas
avoir l'air fatigué donc c'est pas vous
voyez ce qui leur voix là elle cherche
quelque chose des choses où je sais pas
oui voilà ne veulent pas avoir l'air
fatigué aujourd'hui c'est ça enfin je
voulais j'entendais parler et
sociologues ou autres sur sur les femmes
et l'aspect enfin les femmes les hommes
l'apparence aujourd'hui voilà
l'apparence aujourd'hui à de
l'importance même et non seulement
vis-à-vis de enfin socialement vis à vis
de l'extérieur mais aussi par rapport à
soi même quand on se regarde dans le
miroir le matin voilà dans quel état
d'esprit on est quand on se regarde
voilà
et on a une wii il ya une autre
évolution qui est intéressante au niveau
on reste dans la médecine esthétique ce
qu'est le sujet il ya une autre
évolution qui est intéressante c'est que
aujourd'hui les femmes ont un petit peu
dépassé la ride
si vous voulez on ne se focalise plus
sur la ride comme ça l'a été il ya vingt
ans nos nos mères aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt justement c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est la santé de la peau la
lumière de la peau l'éclat de la peau et
ça c'est un reflet de l'intérieur et là
quand on fait des articles là dessus
c'est vrai que ça peut être de la
médecine esthétique mais il ya aussi de
l'alimentation il ya aussi de l'hygiène
de vie qui rentrent en jeu et ça c'est
une très grande évolution et l'autre
évolution en fait c'est parce que
justement peut-être que pendant un
certain moment on a traité que la ride
en tout cas les médecins ne faisais que
ça parce que peut-être que c'était en
termes de développement de la médecine
c'est par là que ça a commencé par les
produits injectables
les femmes ne veulent pas être
transformés je crois que elles sont
beaucoup plus méfiante aujourd'hui
qu'elle ne l'était peut-être il ya il ya
une dizaine d'années où met-on cinq ans
mais donc du coup comme dit ariane c'est
vrai que c'est plus une harmonie
générale et moi même regardez regardez
parce qu'il ya des délais jeune femme le
fonds de fonds des petites interventions
de plus en plus jeunes et ça se voit
beaucoup moins
vous voyez des femmes d'un certain âge
où on repère qu'elles ont fait quelque
chose parce qu'elle est elles ont eu des
interventions il ya quelques années
qui était assez visible si je puis dire
parce que les gestes n'étaient pas
encore aussi précis que peut-être que
les techniques étaient moins si vous
voulez affiner mais aujourd'hui ça se
boit beaucoup moins et en france est une
école qui s'appelle la french touch qui
est reconnu aux états unis où justement
qui prône le naturel ça qui est
intéressant et qui a été reprise dans
les codes d'injection du botox aux états
unis justement pour éviter d'en mettre
trop il ya vraiment une tendance vers le
naturel c'est à dire que les femmes vous
disent je veux bien je vais faire
quelque chose mais je veux pas que ça se
voir mais enfin je reprendrai sur ce que
disait rien tout à l'heure c'est à dire
que je trouve qu'effectivement elles
sont peut-être moins focalisé sur la
reid est plus sûr c'est plus la texture
de la peau c'est avoir une belle peau
avec sans porc voilà maintenant c'est
plus de porc etc
mais là où je trouve qu'il ya un
paradoxe c'est quand même je trouve
qu'elle je trouve qu'avec l'arrivée du
botox et d'acide hyaluronique même jeune
je trouve qu'elle change de tête
moi je trouve je trouve que vraiment
gens vont enfin peut-être parce que j'ai
l'oeil maintenant mais je trouve que
alors les jeux je les repère tout de
suite
enfin je trouve qu'il ya plein de filles
de femmes plus ou moins jeunes soient se
font faire de la mésothérapie up
elles ont un teint plus plus cirer enfin
je trouve que elle change de tête
vraiment et pourtant ils veulent du
naturel et tout ça mais il ya quand même
je trouve qu'elle quand même un
engrenage
alors il est vrai qu'il ya un engrenage
et que justement
je trouve que l'arrivée de ces gestes
qui sont réversibles
c'est à dire que ce soit les ch'ti cydia
l'ironique au botox vous revenez à votre
état de vieillissement de départ si vous
voulez au bout de six mois fait que dans
votre image corporelle et dans l'image
que vous avez vous vous vous retrouvez
tels que vous êtes donc vous ne perdrez
pas pied par rapport à votre image
alors que si on intervient si elles
interviennent si vous voulez alors que
le produit n'est pas totalement résorbée
où qu elles fondées comme un lifting par
exemple un geste définitif
vous perdez votre image vous voyez de
référence par rapport à votre âge je
crois que ça c'est très très important
cette espèce de réversibilité parce que
vous êtes face à vous avec les quelques
rides ou ça et que là vous décidez j'ai
envie de leur faire ou pas je vais
attendre j'ai pas d'argent ce moment je
peux attendre
voyez je crois que ça c'est très
important et très souvent les femmes qui
virait qui tombe dans une espèce de
dismorphophobie ou dans une espèce de
l'addiction à ce genre de technique
c'est parce que justement elle elle
rentre dans le cycle et elles
n'attendent pas cette espèce de temps où
le temps les rattraper a well le voit
donc c'est certain type de femme mais il
y en ad'autres justement qui ont 7
comment vous dire qu'ils ont cette
prudence et qu'ils disent et nous
d'ailleurs on le dit pas plus de deux
fois par an si vous voulez si oui mais
est-ce que ce n'est pas un problème
ils ont financiers et peut-être aussi
une crainte de la chirurgie esthétique
on appelle la chirurgie esthétique
avec tous les problèmes que l'on voit
parce que il ya quand même beaucoup de
de problèmes dans ce geste éthique même
chez les meilleurs chirurgiens et qui
font que ces femmes utilise tes produits
disons qu'en une réversibilité parce que
ça dure pas ça dure pas des années le
biotox sauf à y revenir en permanence et
ans que ça dure 4 6 mois huit mois six
mois oui à la presse à rome
oui mais le vieillissement revient mais
d'un autre côté parce que c'est pas
passé récent l'a lâché question 1 la
chirurgie esthétique maintenant où ça
s'adresse aux femmes qui ont quand même
plus de chez pas 55 60 ans au plus 50
on propose au point de me démerder
intervention le visage oui je sais mais
il est vrai que la chirurgie esthétique
du vieillissement
oui mais elle attend diminuent sur toute
façon les actifs est en nette diminution
c'est pour ça que les chirurgie
esthétique veulent récupérer les
injections et qui sont en confrontation
avec les médecins esthétiques
comment cependant comment est ce que
vous expliquez que finalement le
phénomène puisse prendre tant d'ampleur
dans certains pays et moi enfin a priori
chez nous on ne serait plus dans la
logique que vous développez du frenchie
touch je crois que c'est que tu faisais
difficile à expliquer toi que c'est
culturel
il y avait des interventions un petit
peu sur des sujets comme ça au congrès
de médecine anti âge à monaco où on
était plus que ça n'est pas parce que
c'est des solutions sont aussi des
ethnies si vous voulez c'est à dire que
dans le monde dans le monde par exemple
en asie il ya une culture de la
blancheur si vous voulez donc ils feront
des actes beaucoup plus pour pour ça et
non pas tellement de rides
vous avez d'autres pays à les traiter le
brésil où par exemple ya une culture du
corps il ya beaucoup plus
d'interventions sur le corps que sur le
visage donc c'est ses traits culturels
en revanche ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'il ya un modèle un petit peu
universel de la femme c'est à dire que
quand on prend des miss
les miss de tous les continents il ya
dix ans et aujourd'hui qu'on met des
photos à côté on s'aperçoit que si vous
voulez qu'elle dans les dents les
critères elles perdent un petit peu leur
caractère de leur continent et qu'il ya
une université la situation où une
mondialisation si vous voulez d'un type
féminin les asiatiques se font débrider
les yeux les voyez ce que je sais c'est
qu'il ya une espèce igaya phénomène de
ce soir il y avait un chirurgien qui
disait quelque chose de très intéressant
dans la cause justement sur le débridage
des yeux il disait que enfin que les
asiatiques qui vivait chez elle en asie
se faisait totalement débridée les yeux
et que celles qui étaient donc qui
vivait par exemple aux états unis le
faisait seulement à moitié comme si elle
voulait garder quand même un petit peu
de leur identité voilà un peu des
identités je crois aussi que dans
certains pays aux etats-unis et
peut-être en amérique du sud aussi c'est
un signe extérieur de richesse de faire
du botox de la charge et esthétique des
injections sait on le monde a su comme
le bronzage a été il ya quelques années
en europe
non mais en europe non mais en revanche
j'ai l'impression que chez les jeunes
maintenance et c'est un peu la chose à
faire se faire faire une à jouer si
c'est un biologiste à la mode ou quoi
c'est un peu à la mode me faire un peu
de botox même à moins de 30 ans ah oui
ah oui ah oui ça c'est un concert c'est
plus tabou du tout maintenant on dit ah
tiens j'ai fait mon petit ange mais j'ai
fait ma petite j'ai pas sur ça c'est ça
c'est oui c'est ça qui est à m alors
c'est un phénomène de société mais ce
qu'il faut si vous voulez ce que je
trouve et kla là-dessus qu'il faut
relever c'est que quand vous commencez à
vous trafic et à 20 ans justement vous
risquez beaucoup plus de perdre cette
image de vous et de refuser le
vieillissement que les générations qui
ont connu ces gestes-là partir de 50 55
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
donc là il va y avoir aussi un problème
psychologique et d'appréhension du
vieillissement qui va être différent
dans ces générations là moi je voulais
quand même dire que les médecins sont
pas tous d'accord pour dire que il ya
plus de jeunes dans leur cabinet
certains médecins le disent et d'autres
non et comme on n'a pas de chiffres en
france vu que moi là mais c'est pas
forcément systématique peut-être qu'il
ya une petite frange de génération qui y
va parce qu'aussi si la mer y est allé
plus la grand mère c'est vrai que ça
finit par être quelque chose de de
banaliser effective c'est peut-être très
parisien et dans un certain milieu
je pense oui mais regardez les
interventions sur les dessins par
exemple il ya eu des demandes de plus en
plus de plus en plus jeune et il ya déjà
des chirurgiens qui sont extrêmement
rigoureux là dessus et qui n'opèrent pas
une jeune fille dessin avant 18 ans et
d'autrui vacances et pour une opération
esthétique je parle pas des opérations
de réduction quand il ya un problème
une dernière une dernière fois
qu'est-ce que vous qui est quand même un
peu des témoins de la société en tout
cas féminine est en partie masculine
puisque vous avez 30 % de refus heures
qu'est ce qui vous préoccupe le plus sur
ce sujet là moi j'avais envie de vous
avez peut-être entendu ça avant mais
j'ai l'impression que la chirurgie
esthétique est assez assez bien encadré
on va dire peut-être avec les histoires
de lipolyse on sait plus trop loin mais
bon mais alors que la médecine
esthétique pas du tout mais enfin pas du
tout c'est à dire que l'autre fois j'ai
entendu quelqu'un qui s'est fait passer
pour un médecin et qui faisait des qui
proposait des ingé son injection de
botox et d'acide hyaluronique qui
n'était pas du tout médecin et qui
injecte finalement des produits que
l'afssaps connaît même elle même assez
mal est là elle a un peu de recul mais
par exemple on se fait injecter du botox
1 20 ans qu'est-ce que si on fait ça
pendant dix ans comment va comment va
finir par réagir on sait pas comment la
poule non plus comment ces illuminés par
le foie je sais pas on sait pas
l'afssaps ne sais pas non plus elle a
quelques retours mais assez peu des
médecins qui traîne un peu les pieds
pour dire
pour signaler les effets secondaires etc
donc je trouve qu'on voit là moi celle
où le botox sur le botox valvo dioxine
dans tous les cas je parle des
injectables en fait oui non mais t'es
pas parler du botox peut-être comme ça
parce que tu as aussi atteint même un
russe de 20 ans de recul et puis dans
d'autres médias s'est paraît parlons
plutôt de l'acide hyaluronique qui est
pas un médicament est donc capable des
mêmes
voilà elle il ya très peu de remonter
alors voilà dont il a pris jeudi kadri
toutes les toutes les injections anti
cellulite
enfin nous tous qui tous voilà donc
maintenant et sont interdites et
heureusement mais voilà en fait décret
non mais je crois que le problème c'est
c'est que c'est que la cia lui aussi
vous voulez vous avez un marché qui est
énorme
un marché qui est mondial à 12 ou 13%
avec un marché qui se développe à 7% sur
l'europe et sur la france bon là dessus
vous à des grosses entreprises qui
arrive pas ce que c'est c'est l'avenir
on sait que ça va se développer qu'on va
faire de l'argent là-dedans donc c'est
très clair à partir de ce moment là vous
avez des acteurs qui sont là depuis
longtemps qui s'y rend heureux vous avez
d'autres qui viennent de pays moins
rigoureux parce qu'on sait d'où ils
viennent et qui font aussi du marketing
alors aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour faire du marketing on prend de
l'acide hyaluronique et on dit ah oui
mais le mien est meilleur parce que j'ai
rajouté un petit toxines et antioxydants
j'ai rajouté une petite molécule de
machin qui va vous faire si qui va vous
faire ça et le problème est que plus
vous rajouter dans ce genre de formules
d un des ingrédients nouveau plus que
vous risquez une allergie ou un problème
et à retardement
c'est à dire qu'on vous injecte quelque
chose
aujourd'hui vous ne faites aucune
réaction deux ans ou trois ans après on
vous réinjecte quelque chose et là vous
faites déclencher une réaction
d'où l'intérêt de d'avoir une rigueur
par rapport à ce qui à l'intérieur est
de savoir ça de ce qu'il ya de la part
du fabricant est ensuite et c'est très
important
ces carnets ont dont on parle à nos à
nos lectrices
il faut savoir ce que vous êtes péage rt
parce que maintenant les générations qui
son âge commencent à se faire injecter à
30 ans elles seront à 60 cantons seront
plus que lorsqu'on est ce qu'on leur
injecter et donc il ya un risque de
croisement des allergènes d'allergies et
de réaction qui va être très important
ça je crois qu'il faut donc nous si vous
voulez très souvent leur dis prenez des
produits classiques avec lequel on a un
recul de 15 ans aujourd'hui les plus
simples les plus propres les plus les
plus simples quelque part parce que vous
avez une seule molécule vous savez ce
qu'on vous injecte mais il faut aussi
demander il faut dire aux lectrices à
nos lectrices et ce qu'on leur dit de
bien savoir ce qu'on leur injecte et de
regarder la boîte il faut le problème
c'est qu'elles veulent pas elles veulent
pas ils ne veulent pas le faire alors ça
ne peut pas passer on est prêts on les
prévient on aimerait bien on les
prévient beau parent papier saint pons
la suisse à ce qui se passe chez vos
électeurs où les médecins esthétiques
qui ne sont pas très rigoureux
on leur offre des produits gratteux
gratuitement pour qu'ils les essayent
pour qui les teste donc ils vont les
tester ils vont les injecter à des
femmes
ils vont elles vont payer comme si elle
avait un produit classique alors que
n'ont pas payé voyez ce que je veux
devront pas payer elles et elles ne
savent ils ne leur disent pas exactement
le produit qu'ils ont injecté pour
certains pas tous âges mais je vous dis
les problèmes qu'il a eus
alors moi je fais attention quand vous
dites non moi je les justes pardon à la
rebondir sur le fait attention ça il
faut pas comprendre qu'un quelques à ben
oui mais le journal
mais bien sûr non mais je veux dire
simplement que les écarts dont il ya des
cas comme ça où les femmes rurales sont
parmi vos quêtes boucle
ce que je demandais pour terminer c'est
est ce que vous avez fait des articles
sur le tourisme esthétique et si vous
avez fait quel a été votre jugement
nous on à la fin je pense si au moins
trois ans à l'époque on parlait où on en
parlait bien sûr où ça ouvrait ces
endroits où vrai où les femmes
commençaient à y aller acheter leurs
billets d'avion
en étant très
circonspect quand même bien sûr surtout
par rapport au suivi c'est pas à la
limite l'acte sur place ça dépend des
pays de législations des pays etc mais
mais c'était surtout met en garde par
rapport au suivi et est en fait par
exemple ne serait ce que par exemple de
se faire poser des implants mammaires et
de revenir huit jours après par avion
voilà quoi
voilà donc on a on a été pas c'était un
phénomène il fallait il fallait traiter
ce phénomène et sujet mais on était bien
entendu très prudent d'autant qu'on
avait pas tellement non plus de recul
toujours pareil nous ce qu'on aime bien
c'est avoir un peu de recul par rapport
à toutes les situations proposées
voilà c'est surtout ça ne se justifie
pas enfin aller se faire opérer par
enfin souvent les femmes ne voit pas le
chirurgien avant il ya des échanges par
mails ou des fins enfin ça paraît assez
aberrant d'aller se mettre entre les
mains d'un d'un médecin à qui on n'a
rien expliqué non mais c'est bien que
non mais c'est loin soirée mais pour
profiter d'un autre moins cher au bénin
mais le problème c'est que ça coûte un
tiers quelquefois de ce que ça coûte en
france c'est ça le c pour ça c'est pour
les dents aussi ça coûte un tiers ça
commençait par les dents et je voudrais
juste rajouter une chose c'est que la
formation des médecins a déjà les
médecins esthétiques et quand même
assuré aujourd'hui par les gens qui
produisent qui fabrique les produits et
moi ce que je voulais dire aussi c'est
qu'il n'ya pas en fait de diplômes
reconnus de médecin esthétique parce que
le terme esthétique et donc est réservé
aux chirurgiens plasticiens
donc il ya plusieurs sociétés savantes
qui forment les médecins mais les
formations sont extrêmement diverses
donc ce serait bien qu'on pas qu'on
réussisse peut-être à mettre au point
une formation reconnue me parle par le
ministère de la santé ou en tout cas que
les femmes puissent savoir à qui elle
s'adresse parce que c'est extrêmement
variés d'accord
d'accord nous y pensons d'ailleurs cette
commission cette mission est fait pour
ça qu'il ya une question qu'on aurait
oublié de vous poser à laquelle vous
souhaiter ardemment répondre non qui en
est nous sommes allés au congrès à
monaco congrès international de mai de
médecine anti âge où il a été absolument
affolé par par la foire commerciale
ah oui parce que le nom de peur pardon
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
pardon ça se fait pas dans cet hémicycle
effectivement sur le marché le marché
qui est en création
énorme non mais ça dépasse les
injections sont les machines mais sont
aussi je vous dis les tests génomiques
les gélules à avaler les et tout ça oui
donc je pense qu'on est là aussi
vraiment justement pour des connivences
et femmes et défendre nos lectrices est
ce qu'on veut c'est que ce soit encadré
et c'est que tout cela soit encadré
aussi c'est encadré ci s'est vérifié
voilà et si de temps à autre
vérification ponctuelle parce que de
toute façon les femmes sont tentés par
sa les hommes et les femmes ne sont eux
pas un exil ne les aurez choisi bien sûr
c'est le cours des choses donc il joue
on ne réduira pas ça donc il faut
prendre des mesures
nous sommes là pour ça voilà merci donc
merci on compte sur vous conçue merci
mesdames
voilà pour cette table ronde pour en
savoir plus ou pour la revoir notre site
internet publicsenat.fr très bonne fin
de journée à tous